what's up everyone thanks for tuning in
I'm currently at monterosso that Amar'e
and Nadia in the Riviera
it is amazing here right on the
Mediterranean and it's much different
sort of geography than we saw in fresh
ening and fresh na we saw the very flat
Mediterranean right next to Rome and
here further up north at the Riviera one
thorough so the Maya we see look at this
I mean that's friggin awesome so yeah
the geology here is incredible people
here are super nice and it's just
gorgeous out the water is amazing
temperature as well it's all it's
actually cleaner than in fresh na check
this out
it's quite clean and amazing super
grateful to be here right now and I've
been doing a little bit of cliff jumping
that's gonna hell of fun and it's just
amazing the Italian Riviera has
definitely stolen a part of my heart I
think California's coast was amazing you
gotta check out Italy's coast much love
maybe I should talk a little bit about
inequality on this episode I think that
there's quite a lot to talk about
regarding inequality it's kind of baked
into our biology and it's very difficult
to admit that inequalities baked into
our biology but it has been it's part of
our nervous system it's part of
evolution the question is then on all
these other rocks that are orbiting
stars is it possible possible that
inequality did not somehow emerge that's
a really interesting question is it
possible that inequality did not emerge
as a part of evolution on other rocks
orbiting stars it's a really interesting
thought experiment how would biology
have had to evolve on that rock in order
for there to have not been any
inequality because you can see from
every single species over the last
couple hundred million of years
you see rampant inequality a very small
percentage of the population of the
species has access to all the mates has
access to all the resources and much
less of it of the of the population of
large percentage population has access
to way way less so stuff like this is
fascinating because it's very scientific
but also in terms of our planet this is
about humanity we are humans you know
we're these [ __ ] advanced chimpanzees
and if we are advanced chimpanzees
really then shouldn't we be able to
figure out how to sustainably prosper
collectively or will there be a
speciation based on wealth inequality I
personally love the idea of helping max
my
people's potential and unleashing their
full creative soul into the world but at
the same time it's extremely difficult
how do you funnel resources down the
hierarchy to people that are desperately
in need of resources to unleash their
creative potential in their soul into
the world so how exactly we do that
let's start a conversation about how to
properly and most effectively maximize
people's souls into the world and how we
do that and we've heard of concepts like
universal basic income and there's
plenty of other ones as well that we
should that was to talk about I really
want to jump back in this place is
amazing
wealth and equality baked into evolution
thought experiment is it possible that
through evolution that somehow
inequality doesn't involve devolve on a
rock or being started challenge you let
me know your thoughts I'd love to hear
what you have to say regarding that do
you think that inequality is baked right
into evolution that every single rock or
being a star that has species evolved
has inequality and what are we gonna do
moving forward about inequality we're
gonna keep it forever are we another
interesting new topic concept that I
think about a lot is me having things
and that you're not precluding you from
having things so at any point any one of
these advanced chimpanzees can just look
at the train Trenitalia it's an amazing
amazing system of trains across Italy
Italy has one of the largest economies
on the planet they're doing incredibly
well and anyway so the utopic concept if
I have something or any advanced
chimpanzee has something it doesn't
preclude another advanced chimpanzee
from having it so at any point anyone
with nanotech with AI with robotics with
resource resource surplus just a
straight abundance of resources to the
extent of which we don't know what to do
with them and especially with nanotech
AI and robotics that at any point you
can just summon that that amazing chair
that amazing home that amazing car that
amazing whatever
the stars do whatever you want so anyway
if everyone can do that whenever they
want to do it maybe that's utopic enough
to the point where we can prosper
collectively without the inequality
problem
so anyway much love everyone thanks for
checking in we're again we're at
monterosso del mar in the italian
riviera and it's been DC mall here I've
been saying that a lot but it's [ __ ]
amazing
again the culture the people
everything's been freakin an awesome
challenge you I challenge you think
about that inequality think about that
evolution is it possible that beings
evolved without inequality on rocks
orbiting other stars much love everyone
what would that look like let me know
please thank you